hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast diagnostic development and
laboratory response to infectious
disease outbreaks I am Christina jewel
of lab roots and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational webinars
seminars presented and sponsored by lab
roots for more information please visit
www m we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we will try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on a screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top of
light of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left this is an
educational webinars and thus offers
free continuing education credits after
the webinar is over please click on the
CD button located at the bottom left
hand corner of your web page and follow
the process of obtaining your credit I
would Wow I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Paula rebell Paula
arabelle PhD dasda bmm obtained her
bachelor's degree at Washington
University in st. Louis and her PhD from
the Washington University School of
Medicine where she studied the bacterial
pathogenesis of your cydia
enterocolitica in dr. Virginia Miller's
laboratory dr. emelles postdoctoral
studies included work on tumor immunise
immunology in dr. Timothy lays
laboratory followed by a fellowship in
medical
Public Health laboratories microbiology
at Washington University barnes-jewish
hospital and st. Louis Children's
Hospital department of pathology and
immunology under the direction of
doctors Mike Dunn and Greg storch doctor
Ravell is currently an assistant
professor of pathology and pediatrics at
baylor college of medicine and clinical
liaison in the medical microbiology
laboratories at Texas Children's
Hospital performer positions include
assistant professor at University of
Texas Southwestern school of medicine
department of pediatric and pathology
director of medical microbiology at
children's medical center of dallas and
director of medical microbiology
laboratories at Texas Children's
Hospital dr. Ravel has a strong interest
in pediatric microbiology with a focus
on a molecular diagnostics as well as an
interest in the evolution of
gram-negative and how microbial
resistance I will now turn it over to
dr. polymer Bell for her presentation
dr. Rubell thank you for that
introduction and thank you to land
routes for inviting me to give this talk
today so as Christina pointed out the
talk today is going to focus on
diagnostic development and the left it's
a response to infectious disease
outbreaks so through the lens of my
experience at Texas Children's Hospital
I'm going to walk you through some
specific outbreaks that we have
experienced and dealt with here at Texas
Children's as well as we'll go through
some historic outbreaks for interesting
at the end of the talk you should be
able to define what an outbreak is as
well as discuss the specific role of the
clinical or medical microbiology labs in
the outbreak scenario and then finally
you should be able to really contrast
this
steps that are required and involved in
the validation of any assay that you may
develop in response to an outbreak and
contrast specifically those essays that
would be FDA cleared or approved versus
those that would be laboratory developed
so we'll go ahead and get started so
what is an outbreak sounds you know it's
not just a title of a movie or something
like that there are a lot of different
definitions that you can think of Marion
Webster describes it as a sudden or
violent increase in activity or an
increase in the incidence of an
infectious disease or an increase in the
numbers of harmful organisms which like
an outbreak of locusts or something like
this so from our perspective we
obviously focus on the disease so the
CDC and this comes from the specifically
the food net or pulse net on resource
which actually is involved in the
investigation of any food borne illness
that may be associated with an outbreak
in the United States their definition is
that when two or more people get the
same illness from the same contaminated
food or drink the event is defined as a
foodborne outbreak the World Health
Organization intends to have a more
global perspective as you would expect
and their definitions are twofold the
first is generally an occurrence of
cases of disease in excess of what you
would normally see in a defined
community geographical area or perhaps
season so point in time benefit they
also make an exception for certain
communica communicable diseases where a
single case that may have been long
absent from the population or caused by
an agent that has not been previously
recognized in the community or area as
an outbreak so an example of that would
be if we in Houston had a case of
diphtheria that would one case alone
would be enough to constitute an
outbreak for us so outbreaks occur in
space and time like anything else and we
define them they
based on the expanse of the region or
the time that they cover so in terms of
location a small or a local outbreak is
what most of us probably see and are
most familiar with on a hospital level a
local outbreak would be an example of an
outbreak in your pic you or your NICU or
for those of you need else enters your
Mick you are sick you on another great
example of a local outbreak would be a
church picnic where everybody ate the
same bag potato salad kind of thing when
we start to think of it in terms of a
more public health perspective there are
also statewide or regional outbreaks
which by definition means it covers
multiple counties within a state and for
some regional long breaks can actually
encompass neighboring states but it
doesn't quite span the nation and once
it does span the nation with multiple
states across the country we consider
that a multistate outbreak and then
finally an international outbreak sort
of self-explanatory outbreaks that
basically cover the globe a great
example of a current international on
break would be the pandemic that we're
seeing with CT XM esbl producing ecoli
so there's a specific urinary tract
community-associated urinary tract ecoli
it's a very very common occurrence
across the globe and this CT XM esbl
gene confers a high level of resistance
so we have patients from all over coming
in from the community with the UTI that
you historically could treat with
bactrim that now requires IV antibiotics
so it's not a specific disease in that
case as it is the resistance phenotype
that makes that an outbreak so in time
operates unfortunately are often defined
retrospectively in terms of either the
outbreak is over before we can
officially define it or it's been
ongoing for a long time and that's
simply because sometimes they can be
difficult to detect not always but
sometimes and they can span very short
period
time or extended periods of time the
challenge is really to detect the
outbreak in a timely manner and such
that we can actually take action to
intervene and hopefully effectively stop
the outbreak or at least shorten it
through our intervention it good so
we'll walk through a couple of historic
outbreaks and then we'll get into more
contemporary time so the first outbreak
that I think always deserves mention
from an infectious disease perspective
is the black death or the play
essentially and this outbreak was caused
by a gram-negative organism called
Yersinia pestis it's his grand- bacteria
and it was carried by little fleas that
infect rats and it caused bubonic or
pneumonic plague during the 1300s in
medieval times essentially there are
estimates that as high as 75 million
people died when the Earth's population
was only 450 million total so this was
hugely devastating there's nothing that
could even come close to it with what we
see in current time half of Europe died
for example in four years so this is the
you know the granddaddy of all outbreaks
if you will and we're very fortunate to
not have to deal with anything quite
this significant today today probably
the most common and the most significant
outbreak that we deal with every year is
influenza so influenza causes yearly
epidemics that are caused because their
genetic composition changes just
suddenly we call it antigenic drift so
the viral genome actually subtly changes
with time due to the nature of its
replication and every year the virus can
change enough that it can kind of
breakthrough and cause another epidemic
that's why we have to constantly be
diligent in terms of observing which
viruses circulating and updating our
vaccine pandemics actually happen when
the virus does what we call a shift so
this is
the virus itself has a segmented genome
and when those segments RIA sort so
commonly we see swine avian and human
any kind of shuffling that's typically
when we see a pandemic during a typical
epidemic or outbreak of influenza during
a typical season we see anywhere from
150 to about 250 deaths yearly so this
is not trivial even today most severe
cases are in the very very young or in
the very old and the elderly and people
will be angry because this is not my
definition but they say elderly is over
65 I didn't come up with that number but
essentially greater than ninety percent
of our fatalities occur in older
patients during typical epidemic
outbreaks pandemics are different
pandemics the best most dramatic if you
will example and influenza pandemic
occurred during the nineteen eighteen
spanish flu pandemic essentially a third
of the world's population is estimated
to have been infected with this virus
and the unfortunate thing is that the
virus had a death rate of two and a half
percent and thus there was an estimated
death of ron cey's me fifty to a hundred
million cases in fact you may know this
but the pandemic spanish flu actually
caused more deaths than World War one so
it was hugely impacting as many of these
can be our recent memory will bring to
mind 2009 the at that point in time we
called it swine flu it's now a novel
h1n1 but the 2009 pandemic actually
resulted in one hundred and twenty two
hundred to two hundred thousand deaths
but the significant thing and this is
the case with all influenza pandemics
that differentiates them aside from just
the overall number of those that become
infected because it's a naive background
is that most of these deaths during the
2009 pandemic occurred in patients that
were less than 65 so these were normal
healthy
many of whom died as a result of
contracting the virus so I'm going to
talk about a lot of other outbreaks
today but I'd like to just remind
everyone that into lenses still today is
the leading infectious cause of death
among children and young adults in the
US and I always give a talk with at
least one point saying you should get
your flu shot so that's my plug for
today I have no association with
influenza shot development I just think
it's good for your health good for the
help of your community good for the
health of our children so another
current outbreak is actually a bacterial
outbreak and this is something that was
picked up on by the CDC due to our food
net or pulse net which is this
infrastructure we have within the u.s.
that the CDC through the various State
labs track speed born outbreaks so on
june first of 2016 the CDC announced
that they were doing a multi-state
investigation due to outbreaks of shikha
toxin-producing ecoli this in this case
0121 so the most famous sugar toxin
producing a cola is the 01 57 and if
you'll think back to the jack-in-the-box
outbreak where we actually saw a
fatality is associated with it when the
undercooked meat this is another example
of a shaky toxin-producing e.coli and as
of July 25th there have been 46 people
that have been infected across 21
different states so this is a national
outbreak fortunately there have been no
deaths but this outbreak was through all
the investigations that have been done
linked to General Mills power and so
that may be why your kroger or shnooks
or wherever your grocery store is may
have sent you a note or called you to
say hey if you bought this two-pound bag
of flour please return it it's not
healthy so that's an example of a
pronoun the current outbreak that we're
dealing with so this slide just
demonstrates that
every day there's something new you can
all you have to do is just turn on the
news we have Ebola you have yellow fever
we have MERS which is the Middle Eastern
respiratory virus which is a coronavirus
similar to SARS which is now on the
cover of Newsweek you see here Blue Bell
ice cream recall due to listeria
chikungunya you name it Zika we've got
it so we always have to be alert to
these outbreaks so what's the role of
the clinical lab what's the role my role
is a lab director or clinical consultant
and that is twofold so essentially our
first and always biggest priority as a
clinical lab is the patient perspective
our job is to identify a specific
infectious agent and provide data that
would allow the physician to
appropriately treat so if it's a
bacterial infection that's antimicrobial
data through susceptibilities if it's
viral it may simply be just
identification of the organism so that
they know it's influenza let's
prescribed tamiflu from a public health
perspective it's more complicated and we
play essentially roles as Sentinel
centers so clinical labs are like the
Canaries in the coal mine if you will we
are the early detector so the first case
of that sugar toxic producing e.coli
0121 was somebody's clinical lab and so
our role is to detect and identify and
report and we have a very
well-established reporting structure
through our local infection control
through our state national public health
and then all the way up to the CDC and
finally not all labs may have this
capacity but many do in such as ours and
that is to assess relatedness of the
organisms so when you think about it
even if this doesn't go beyond just your
own individual hospital it's important
to know whether these bugs that you
might be detecting Ardis random and
sporadic or are they truly related and
thus by definition constitute an
outbreak so what do we look for we look
for some specific pathogen so Listeria
brucella shigella salmonella anthrax
measles
um but those are not the only thing that
constitute a potential outbreak we also
look for any increase in what we might
refer to as a normal human pathogen so
pneumococcus are staph aureus if we see
an increase in numbers that may be
enough to alert us to something going on
um also it's important to note that we
I'd sorry i'm in a conference room that
just shut the lights off on i wasn't
moving enough and we identify any
uncommon resistance patterns or
potentially new resistance patterns and
that's one of the things i alluded to
earlier in terms of the CTX mcs BLS
carbapenem-resistant Enterobacteriaceae
are a great example of that this is
something that if we see this type of a
bug that we don't normally see in our
population we need to identify and
communicate and then also obviously the
identification of any new or uncommon
pathogen so who do we help when we do
this our priority is always to the
individual patient but it goes beyond
that and this really is a public health
issue so we help the health of the
hospital the local community the
national community and the global
community by all playing a part in terms
of this team of investigators who can
help detect and potentially stop these
outbreaks so how do we identify these
pathogens in the clinical lab frankly we
don't have any special magic tool kits
we just use our traditional methods so
for bacterial identification we we grow
bacteria we grow a virus and we culture
them and then identify them using
traditional methods there's also an
evolving field of molecular detection
that allows us to detect things in
particular in the realm of biology
faster than we could with many of our
old traditional methods and then in some
instances we may never be able to
culture these bugs and so everything is
defined and detected simply by serologic
detection which is looking at the host
and how did the host respond to this
virus to determine whether or not or
bacteria to determine whether or not
they've been infected so this is a an
example of one of our local outbreaks
that we dealt with and essentially in
mid-april we had an MRA identified from
a routine blood culture of one of our
patients in the NICU it's not coming but
one sporadic case like that does not
make an outbreak and it doesn't even
raise too many red flags when you have
very large nikki's like we do this type
of infection is unfortunate what can
happen but in early May we had one of
our bench techs and this emphasizes that
this is not um just a one-man game it's
really a team game and many of these
investigations that you'll hear about
today the first person to be that that
canary in the coal mine was just a bench
tech who happen to be paying close
attention and said hey you know what I
feel like I've noticed more mrs a
isolates lately and so that word leads
to myself as a director to do a little
bit deeper investigation and notify it
our infection control and indeed we did
assess that we had an increase in our
number of mrs a isolates so after that
the laboratory we went ahead and did an
assessment of potential relatedness and
by that i mean you can have just a
random increase in numbers that are true
true and unrelated so we may have an
increase in mrs a infections but may may
have nothing to do with each other so we
went ahead and did that assessment and
indeed we did have a total strain that
was causing these infections and so at
that point in time infection control
really initiates a formal investigation
to look for the source and to implement
the bundles and practices that we need
to actually stop the outbreak so this is
what a picture of what I'm describing as
our assessment of relatedness and
essentially I'm going to try my best to
draw an arrow here this group here so 13
21 if you look all of those isolates
actually have the same what i would call
banding pattern
and by that I mean if you look at each
of these little bands they are unique
they are unique for 18 17 16 15 and 14
but if you look at those from 13 through
one they all have the same banding
pattern and you can tell by down below
here you may not I'm not sure how well
does projects but this is the percent
similarity and so essentially all of
those 13 through 17 here at around
almost ninety eight percent similarity
so that really does indicate that we're
looking at the same bug so what's our
biggest challenge in the lab and I'd say
that the biggest challenge is how do you
detect something when you don't know
what it is so we always need to be alert
to these outbreaks but we may not even
know what it is that we're looking for
um and I apologize for fellow Iowans I'm
a native Iowan and so I can make fun of
Iowa in this slide and this is really
what I have is my image for what started
that influenza pandemic of 2009 the
mixing of the human and the swine so I'm
going to walk you through now what our
experience was in terms of really
something that no one had ever seen
before and that is a completely novel
and new influenza virus and how our lab
was actually able to respond and react
appropriately so this is a timeline that
initiates back in excuse me early April
of 2009 there's a 39 year old woman who
dies in Mexico of what at that point I'm
was called an atypical pneumonia then on
the 20th we hear reports of over 800
cases of this mysterious atypical
pneumonia in Mexico City so clearly
there's something there is an outbreak
in Mexico City what is it nobody knows
that
time and fortunately or unfortunately
however you want to look at it for us we
then saw in excuse me mid to late april
there were two cases of pediatric what
at that point time was called swine
influenza and children in southern
california so on april 27 the wh 0
raised its pandemic alert level 24 which
means that there is human-to-human
transmission and it's enough to sustain
community level outbreaks and then
unfortunately on that same day in in
houston in our emergency department we
had the first reported death in a child
who had traveled to houston from Mexico
who had h1n one so this was sort of the
opening of the floodgates for us so our
diagnostic capacity at that date and
time was that we had the rapid flu which
you all know it's just the little thing
where you go into your doctor's office
they stick a swab in your nose and tell
you yes or no you have influenza okay we
didn't have any idea whether or not the
existing rapid influenza tests could
detect this novel virus if it could how
well could it detect it and if it told
us it was blue a we couldn't some type
so we didn't know enough about whether
or not we really were seeing that novel
virus we had culture but that was slow
and we couldn't subtype there either and
there were no molecular detection assets
so you might ask well at that point in
time what what were the actual number of
commercially available molecular assays
to detect influenza the answer to that
was zero so no matter how many years
pediatricians had been saying to various
companies we really would like and
influenza molecular tests you know that
just wasn't what people were interested
in before the pandemic things are
different now but at that point in time
there were none so one thing that is
important to know about houston is every
year we worry about hurricanes in
houston and i put this picture here up
because at TCH still today
we have the legacy of Carla and that is
everybody has to have in their office if
your essential hospital personnel you
have what's called the parlia- if the
hurricane hits in Houston shuts down you
stay in the hospital doesn't so we can
continue to run in a crisis situation
and that's one of the things the Texas
Children's does very well is crisis
management when i arrived in texas i
arrived actually on april 9th that year
2009 and i got called into the command
center on that day on april twenty
seventh and they had one question for me
and they said can we test for this virus
so my answer to them was well we have a
couple of options and they were that
number one and number two were that we
could potentially do what we call a
laboratory developed a say to detect all
influenza a using molecular means and
then to potentially subtype or we could
just wait because at that point in time
we knew that the CDC had an essay but
they had not released the sequences even
the State labs nobody else could do
testing except the CDC so knowing that
fortunate for us the two cases in
California that had been reported in the
children in California they had
sequenced both of those viruses the
complete genome and deposited into
genbank and that actually is a goldmine
for laboratories with the capacity to do
diagnostic development because it
allowed us the access to the information
what we call in silico to know what we
needed to turn it in terms of a
molecular SI so at that point time
rather than wait we decided to go
forward with our development of a
homebrew assay so what do you have to do
to do something like that to bring in sa
like that up well assay development SI
optimization and validation sounds easy
one two three but it's not quite as
straightforward as it sounds and it's
important to remember that there are a
variety of regulatory agencies who are
always looking over our shoulder as
laboratory ins when we do this kind of
test development so first and foremost
there's the FDA and the food and drug
administration
what they do is they regulate the
development of tests primarily by
manufacturers who are then going to
distribute the test the College of
American Pathologists is more pertinent
to those individual labs who may develop
a test and then only use it within their
own patient population and then
obviously all labs are have to abide by
the clinical laboratory Improvement
Amendments or quia so in terms of the
FDA designations and what the FDA does
for device manufacturers and i will be
using the term device when i'm
describing an essay a detection essay
and that's simply because as far as the
FDA is concerned all laboratory
developed tests are our actual medical
devices so there are two different types
of clearance or designations that you
can get through the FDA even one is a by
10k referred to as fda cleared and the
second is referred to as fda approved so
any manufacturer who makes a kit that
can actually sell it to a clinical lab
and that you can then test and use in
your lab it's either FDA cleared or its
FDA approved if it's not it receives a
designation of what you would hear as
research use only and typically if it is
an are you O or research use only you
cannot report it clinically unless
you've done a complete internal
validation which we'll talk about in a
bit but the big difference between an
FDA cleared test and an fda-approved
test is simply the level of AB data that
is required for that designation so any
FDA approved acid actually has gone
through extensive clinical trials and
there is data from real patients that
can say this is how this essay impacts
patient care so great examples using
outcome data are HIV quantitative HIV
qualitative these are FDA approved
assays most of the assays that you're
familiar with so whether it's influenza
or any of the other viral respiratory
detection kits that are out there
they're called FDA cleared and that is
means that the laboratory performance
has been established it doesn't mean
that it's definitely it's gone through
extensive clinical trials to show that
the patient outcome is better when this
test is used so what about all the other
tests a lot of tests done are not things
that we get commercially from the app or
from companies that have been cleared or
approved by the FDA they're what we call
laboratory-developed Esther L DTS so
these assays include anything that's
developed internal to your own lab
through research and development but
importantly also anything that is a
modification of an existing FDA cleared
or proof test so those modifications can
be what seems trivial to you but it's
enough to mean that this is now a
laboratory developed test and the
validation process is extensively
different so if you change the specimen
type if you change the collection device
the assay platform the extraction
platform if you make any modification to
that test it becomes a laboratory
developed test so validation what do you
do well for an unmodified fda-cleared or
poop test we have to establish accuracy
reproducibility the portable range
reference range and accuracy in this
instance this is a Miss misnomer I don't
know Hana let's see if I can make a big
X through this that should be gone so to
ignore that right there um the accuracy
in this case simply means agreement so
you need to show that if the company
says this if the test says this business
is positive in the company's hands then
you need to be able to come up with the
same result reproducibility simply means
it's precision so if tech a does it and
tech be does it and they both do it five
times it's the same answer all five
times reportable range means that when
you're doing this validation you should
really evaluate things at both the high
and low levels and the reference range
means that you really should be
documenting that you're not detecting
things below the what we call the limit
of detection so
oh that has to be done anytime you
validate any test in house but if you
are developing your own laboratory
develop test or modifying any FDA test
you also have to establish the
analytical sensitivity and specificity
so that it means how sensitive is that
test in terms of its ability to pick up
and then how specific is it is it
cross-reacting if you're looking for
influenza A and you're calling it
influenza bet a you need to make sure
that it's not going to be positive if
it's rhinovirus if it's gloubi whatever
the case may be so think of specificity
is kind of cross reactivity and
sensitivity is how sensitive is this
tool to be able to detect this test so
I'll emphasize again the biggest
difference there in the validation of an
fda-cleared test versus validation of a
lab develop test is that additional
analytical sensitivity and specificity
so this is just some information from
sources that can help you through your
validation process the Q matech 31 a
it's titled the verification and
validation of procedures in the clinical
microbiology laboratory they actually
have sort of a nice guideline in terms
of what you should do for validation of
an assay and if you have a calf
inspector come through and they want to
look at your validation chances are
they're going to reference this Q matech
is what you should have done is the
minimum validation requirements they
recommend a minimum of positive
specimens 100 negative specimens for
laboratory-developed tests so that means
sorry the lights just went off again um
you're good that means if you are doing
a lab developed test you can't just test
10 specimens and say that's good the FDA
cleared assays and the approved assays
all you have to do is show agreement so
a minimum of 20 specimens and you should
have roughly ten positive and 10
negative but you need to show agreement
with another another validated platform
with those numbers so back to influenza
we had decided to do a complete
laboratory-developed test in
so what that means is we started out
with and this is the and it really is
not projecting well here but over here
you can see all of these or viruses a
variety of h3 and to h1 and one across
the years but these are all influenza a
viruses and this here is the genomic
sequence as was published on GenBank for
of the matrix gene of all of these
different viruses and so what you can
see here highlighted in yellow was an
area of complete similarity that means
every single one of those little letters
the 80 CS and G's they're all exactly
the same within this region down here
there are a few differences like it can
be an A or 80 and over here likewise
there are a couple of AIDS versus tease
so these regions though as you can see
regardless across the years and across
the subtype the matrix gene is highly
conserved so it's a great target to pick
if you're going to look for all
influenza a and that's what we did this
is where we chose our forward primer
this is where we chose our reverse
primer and this is where we chose our
pro so we went forward based on that
with our validation and when we did the
validation it was kind of an ongoing
validation because what what you have to
have is a gold standard so obviously
there were no existing fda-cleared
assays at that time so our gold standard
was the molecular a say that the CDC was
performing we couldn't do it ourselves
we didn't have the primers and probes
but at that point in time we were
sending every single positive that we
had to the CDC and at the beginning they
were turning them around pretty quickly
as the numbers increased and as the
awareness across the country became
greater the time to result from the CBC
he became longer and longer but it
allowed us to go through our validation
process nonetheless and what you see
here is
that we have our essay here this is our
home brew rt-pcr positive and negative
and the cdcs a positive and negative and
so we have complete agreement here and
one hundred percent specificity and
sensitivity this was early in the
validation so you'll note that we
weren't quite to the 50 positives yet
but it's just a snapshot in time when we
actually compared to culture our culture
to our pcr the results were actually
quite shocking and that's what this line
is showing here and that is that we had
292 culture negative but pcr positive
specimens that means that the
sensitivity for our culture was just
below sixty percent so had we decided to
only use culture as an identification
method we would have missed almost fifty
percent of our positive patients so this
is what the results came out for our EIA
or the rapid flu as you remember and as
you can see ya a positive negative rapid
or excuse me I a positive negative real
time PCR positive or negative so again
this is the important number 378 blue-
rapid tests were indeed positive by the
PCR that's a sensitivity of less than
fifty percent that's not even as good as
a good clinician so it's very good that
we didn't depend on what at that point
in time was our existing tool to detect
this virus so what did we learn through
this whole process we learned that you
know the real-time assay is more
sensitive than the rapid or the culture
and we also realize that we could using
our own staff and our own processes
really turn these assays around or turn
the tests around in time to impact
patient care so this is back to our
timeline we the day we lost that patient
ordered our primers in
probes and started our validation and it
was three days later that the CDC
finally released their primers and
probes but we were all well underway in
terms of testing and validating our
essay so we decided to go forward with
our home brew essay on 51 our
preliminary data looked good we had the
50 positives that we needed it just
shows the significant numbers of
patients that we were seeing through
this time and by 521 we were testing any
patient who presented with respiratory
illness to our hospital with this
real-time assay importantly and this is
a very important note as of jun 1st labs
that were using the cdc assay started
running into massive shortages of
reagents so they couldn't get the
supplies that they needed to be able to
do the test and that was a real
eye-opener for us we hadn't anticipated
that one but by the first week in June
we tested over a thousand specimen and
roughly 300 of them were spying positive
and we continued throughout the next
essentially two years with this testing
so we learned that our standard methods
weren't going to work and we really
really really needed the in-house
development we also learned importantly
and these are two very important points
here and the one is that the commonly
available agents in these situations
where you have a massive outbreak where
you have this big surge and infection
common reagents that everybody else are
using can become shortage or the you
know the limiting factor infrastructure
specimen delivery all these things were
critical and we learned you know we had
doctors bringing Sam's freezer bags
holding patient specimens going through
with patient identifiers it was a zoo we
were seeing about 300 patients an hour
through our ed just because of int'l
enza so we also learned that automation
is critical these high throughput
platforms really can save us in these
types of outbreak situations and then
also and this is an important lesson in
it
not a negative about the CDC and our
public health infrastructure and all but
we did learn that the CDC and our state
labs cannot give us results in time to
impact patient care or infection control
practices and when you think about it
that's not their job you know their job
is to maintain the public health
infrastructure of the country not to
respond for that that patient the
initial patient that's our job that's
the clinical labs job and that's why our
ability to develop and implement these
assays in house and not exclusively
depend on our public health
infrastructure is critical so we
finished the pandemic I was going to be
the end of the story we're going to
worry about it anymore but then we had a
few years where we didn't think too much
just the little local Salmonella
outbreaks you know maybe Listeria here
and there with our Blue Bell ice cream
and everybody loves in Texas but we
didn't quite have anything quite as
scary as the pandemic until we receive a
call from our colleagues in Dallas with
Ebola virus so you know Ebola seemed
like an exotic disease very very far
away in West Africa and to be honest
with you as a lab director it really
wasn't high on my list of things that I
was even thinking about until we got
this call and that is the index patient
on develop symptoms in late-september
2014 about four days after arriving to
the US from West Africa and when he
started feeling ill he presented to the
community hospital valles health friends
beat on sep tember 26 he came back to
the hospital and was admitted on the 28
and convert our testing done confirmed
that he did indeed have a bola virus
disease and he died on october eight so
this was a huge eye-opener because any
of you who are geography buffs should
know that dallas is just up 45 it's
about three and a half hours north of us
and so if it can happen there you know
it can happen to us very easily so post
in next case we saw two
additional cases and the first was the
one of the nurses who actually cared for
the index patient she was
self-monitoring for fever so she
presented to the hospital with low-grade
fever was diagnosed with Ebola and then
recovered and release from the NIH
critical care center on October 24 and
the third case was also a health care
provider who cared for the index case
again self monitored everything worked
like clockwork went to Emory was
admitted recovered but it was a real
eye-opener for us in terms of we need to
be able to respond not just to outbreaks
in terms of detection and you know surge
capacity but some of these viruses that
are extremely infectious and extremely
dangerous we also need to have
additional capacity there and so our
response to this was that we opened the
first pediatric special isolation unit
in the country and what this is here you
can see in this picture this room here
is actually the patient room and so
there are no beds here at this point in
time because this is right prior to
opening but what you can see is this
little ante room here has many of the
monitors and computers so when you are
going to enter a patient's room and
you're really just looking and
monitoring and looking at the monitors
you're not going to lay hands on the
patient not going to you know actually
listen to their heart this kind of thing
having all of these separated out to
this relative to this room was is
critical and this is this is room is all
under negative pressure and importantly
the observation windows allow people to
visualize but not be in the room and
then we have additional development for
the siblings and families in terms of
play rooms and things like this that are
removed from but nearby this isolation
unit and there is a bsl-3 laboratory
which means that we have the capacity to
work with pathogens not you don't want
to be growing Ebola obviously it to be a
sophomore but in terms of detection
working whether it's TV whatever the
case may be we do have a specialized
dedicated lab immediately adjacent to
these rooms so
we also decided we had to devote develop
or implement i should say animal virus
assay because we couldn't very well you
know knowing how easy it is for somebody
to walk off an airplane and present to
your Center not have the ability to do
this so there were two commercially
available kits at that time one was what
we call high complexity which means it
required multiple touches a
highly-trained molecular tech to run the
essay the other was what we call a
sample to answer so that's these kits
that are these and clothes little
pouches or cartridges whichever the case
may be where you simply insert your
specimen put it on the machine and it
can see the answer so excuse me we opted
to go with the sample to answer and we
validated using contrived or spiked
specimens and unfortunately we never had
to use the essay we did have a handful
of patients that presented and actually
were flown from DC in various areas in
the country to the special isolation
unit from West Africa based on symptoms
but unfortunately all of the patients
simply had sleep so that was good um now
our next and current outbreak that we're
dealing with is Zika and so what is Zika
it's a virus that actually arrived in
the Americas probably to Brazil from
french polynesia between May and
December of 2013 and in August of 2014
physicians in northeastern Brazil began
to investigate an outbreak of what
really symptomatically looked a lot like
dengi so then in May researchers
determined using rt-pcr that that
illness was actually caused by the Zika
virus and it wasn't until October of
2015 that an increase in the number of
reported cases of microcephaly was
reported to the Brazil Ministry of
Health and by January of 2016 there were
almost 4,000 suspected microcephaly
cases associated with Zika in the early
days we obviously didn't know whether
that was just an association true
related but it now we now do know that
the Zika virus actually does cause these
significant birth defects so what is
Zika it's a flavivirus it's closely
related to dengue it's mostly related to
West Nile yellow fever and these viruses
are all spread by mosquitoes they're
spread by the 80s mosquito which we have
in Houston which we have in Florida
which we have in many parts of the
country you can also see transmission
from mother to trial through a maternal
cradle transmission and through sexual
contact the symptoms are very
nonspecific and really don't negatively
impact the individual unless the patient
is pregnant you can see these severe
birth defects such as microcephaly which
was our primary concern as a pediatric
center we do now have a handful of cases
of what we call local or top fittest
transmission and that means that the
individuals with Zika did not travel to
Central America or Brazil or wherever
and come back with the virus it was not
travel associated they actually acquired
the virus in South Florida so this is
just a map and what you can see is this
represents the dark blue so Texas
California Florida Georgia these are all
states where we've had more than 50
positive Zika cases however all of these
solid-colored states are travel
associated only okay and then the
lighter the color the fewer the cases
okay down here in Florida is the one
exception where it's dark blue they've
had more than 50 cases and they have
this hatch line here that indicates that
there actually has been local spread and
so this obviously is critical in terms
of our thinking of the ability to check
this fire simply because we have a not
just a large standing pediatric center
but we also have a large standing
women's hospital where we deliver
hundreds and thousands of babies and you
know we have a lot of very
nervous moms we are in an area where we
have the mosquito we are in an area
where we have a tremendous amount of
travel back and forth in Mexico South
Central America so we really decided
that we needed to be on the forefront of
this ahead of time rather than be caught
up on the back end so we decided to go
ahead and develop an assay to detect the
Zika so with collaboration with
Methodist Hospital in the Ellie Simmonds
viral foundation we were able to develop
the essay the first available in the
u.s. to detect this virus and how did we
do that we actually started testing in
February 22nd and we test um using
real-time pcr CRM amniotic fluid urine
and CSF we test monday through friday
and / to cdc the serum is what we test
within the first seven days of symptom
onset the amniotic fluid we use to
diagnose intra uterine infection and we
do offer testing we have a special Zika
clinic for women who have clinical
illness within two weeks of travel and
we know that urine can be positive with
30 days with up to 30 days postinfection
so we actually went with an assay in
that case that was commercially
available in europe but there were no
fda-approved assays and we did a similar
type of validation that we saw with
Ebola where we use what we call
contrived samples so we spiked specimens
with a virus that we've received from
one of our colleagues who is a
researcher in Colombia and that allowed
us to validate the essay and then go
live and I would emphasize um you know
Zika is a bad a bad player if you're a
pregnant mom and I've been a pregnant
mom before and I know there are a lot of
things out there to stress you out so
just remember the best defense against a
virus like this is to simply wear
mosquito repellent so that's all I have
today and if anyone has any questions
you can type them into the queue
a otherwise um thank you very much for
your time thank you for that informative
presentation dr. Ravel before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the brain committed button at the
lower is left of the presentation window
we will try to answer as many questions
as we can as the questions come in and
dr. Ravel did you have any last comments
before we answer any questions sorry I
was going to type it in no I mean you
know I would just emphasize that every
lab has to remember that we're all part
of this system and it's our role is the
sentinel centers to really play a key
part in the health of our public health
infrastructure I guess one final plug
that I would have is even if your lab
doesn't do the types of assay
development or um you know homebrew lab
developed tested our lab does I would
like to emphasize the importance of
reporting and sending isolates to the
CDC through your state health lab
because that's really what allows us to
go from the isolated Hospital type
outbreak to knowing and ensuring the
health of our regions in our countries
is this global public health
infrastructure that we have and our
global public health infrastructure is
really only as good as those of us who
contribute on the front end on the front
line so I would just emphasize that and
that's it
thank you again doctor Ravell and it
looks like we don't have time to answer
any questions today but as you did
submit some ravel can answer them via
email I want to remind you that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through December 7 2016 you will
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event see you
next time goodbye